i have to say the georgia
runoff elections on january the 5th i'm
going to say this out loud they're more
important than the presidential election
they are they're that important how
close is it
right now it's neck and neck and we're
both races for both for both races and
there's money pouring couple hundred
million there's money pouring in from
all over the country because these two
races are effectively a referendum on
socialism so
are you know if you keep the senate
read then you can negotiate
i think for smarter programs if you get
this blue wave
and the senate flips to the democrats
and the democrats control the house and
the senate
and the administration and they start to
legislate in universal basic
income again these are programs
that are designed to pay people to not
work well
no problem pride in that say it's
january 6
we wake up the you know liberals win
both okay so now it's 50 50 with the
tiebreaker going to kamala harris
right say that all of a sudden kamala
harris has power
exactly exactly and kamala's more left
than biden is
more way some caller further left than
even sanders but let's just say she's
more left than biden is right let's just
keep keep that part
january 6th they win both what happens
you get chatter about the new green deal
i mean you're talking about tell me
chatter versus execution because chatter
has been going on
do you think things will be executed of
course so give me what things would be
executed
i mean we are talking about health care
for everybody we're talking about
universal basic income we are talking
about
the idea of paying people to be out of
work
for ever and that is just so
anti-american we are not
we have no reason to to vote socialism
into law
and kiss our economy goodbye and watch
china
rise up because i can guarantee you that
if china is in any way interfering
with this election it is pouring money
into those two democratic candidates
period end full stop because if we go
socialist
that is the nail in the coffin of
capitalism and we can
kiss our reserve currency status goodbye
the greenback will no longer have
hegemony on the world stage all of these
and we get inflation by the way
and we get inflation because we stop
worrying about debt and deficits
when people running the country don't
think that there's any consequence
for a 10 trillion dollar 2021 2022
spending spree so it's basically dogs
and cats
living together it's anarchy but but
let's go there okay let's just say it
happens
okay and let's just see we have to yeah
i want to go there let's just say
universal basically can come
passes and andrew yang becomes a uh
you know he's already said he's
potentially running for mayor of new
york city no no
okay so is a half dozen other people we
can name yes but yes
yes well by the way he's a he's a
credible name to run let's just yeah
yeah so viable so
your valuables the right one so so but
let's just say we're there
january 6th happens and then at this
point of the game
everyone calls biden now that you have
it aoc you know
the whole defense we got to make climate
change a part of that budget next
is the universal basic income it's next
medicare for all
health care for all unemployment
benefits extended
you know uh uh extreme regulation
extreme censorship
everyone a possible uh uh court packing
that we can raise it from
seven to nine to 11 to 13 to 15. let's
just say we go there the sky is the
limit
but let's just say we go there you know
the the part that i wanna ask and i i
ask i ask
larry arn who's the president of
hillsdale college which i don't know if
you're familiar with hillsdale college
they're one of the oldest universities
it's conservative you know they've had
some incredible people that have gone to
that university
and they get also a lot of criticism
because they're in michigan i think
they're in michigan
uh uh kai can you check to see where
they're based out of i think they're out
of michigan so they're you know they're
dealing with the governor whitmer you
know all that other stuff
the question i ask is the reagan quote
thank you the ranking quote which is
what we're all one generation away from
losing
our freedom okay we're one generation
away from losing our freedom okay
that's true today well that's what i
want to ask
is it is it that scary to say oh my gosh
we will never have what we had here
because once we go here's a tipping
point you can't ever go back to it
or is it just another time where people
are just
overly panicking and using their panic
to make sure people vote on the right
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna play socrates
here for a minute go for it have you
ever seen any
government program rolled out that was
then rolled back
great question i agree with you i agree
with you
and you are by the way but can you ask
that one more time no
it's very important can you ask that one
more time have you ever seen a
government program
rolled out that was not rolled back you
mean social security medicare and
medicare i mean there's 81 try canceling
social security there's 81
different they try to talk about what
she's saying about that i'm talking
about the 81 different social programs
and under the obama administration you
had the quietest stealthiest
expansion of the social safety net in
u.s history because the federal reserve
slammed interest rates down to zero
percent and allowed the company
the company country if we ran it like a
company it would be a different country
no doubt about it but
but allowed the debt to be run up
magnificently
so that that that set the stage for
where we are but none of those programs
have been even reformed much less rolled
back and you you're delivering a message
to
children you're saying you're saying all
that student debt let's just take that
1.78 trillion dollars let's just expunge
it
i mean how does that make people like me
feel who had to work their asses off to
pay off their student debt not so good
but you're teaching young americans an
un-american way of life
is it something you think that they
would implement
all the above meaning cancel social
security medicare for all
new green deals okay this like so here
we go
here's my follow-up question so i can
set you up danielle
hey i don't in my opinion maybe some of
that gets done i don't think all of it
get done i'd like your hands
because of the house okay and that's my
next question it cannot because of the
house
but that's my next question is where do
the midterm elections come into this
immediately the midterm elections are
already in play because they have
dragged their feet on this stimulus bill
in the dead of winter so how can play
though
you have to go back 20 years to find
a as slim as a majority as we have right
now
in the house of representatives there
was
a quiet gop revolution
heading into this presidential election
you have to go back
20 years to find a congress with a
slimmer and it was it was a gop congress
at the time
but they had the slimmest margin
pelosi's got an even slimmer
margin than that so independence
moderate democrats are going to be
easily swayed
if you start to see some of socialism
tight
light legislation fast you're going to
see democrats
and independents cross the aisle and
vote against
i think is good i think that's healthy
for america that's what people don't
appreciate is the house is not locked
and because because of the slimness of
the majority because so many
seats in the house of representatives
flipped to the geo even
senators like my guy joe manchin in west
virginia he's already come out and said
look like
i'm a red state democrat in in in west
virginia
i'm not just gonna tow the senate line
i'm gonna
so i think that's something that is
gonna be very unique i think we
we understand that biden is going to be
the president i said it
i think people are going to be willing
to negotiate
and broker deals and cross the line and
yeah but what i'm what i'm thinking
and do all that but it's a whole
different dynamic than what we've been
using here's where i'm going
to here's where i'm going to what
leverage does the right have
if they win the if they win senate what
lever so you come to the negotiating
table what leverage do you have
what's your leverage for that two years
before midterms
the republicans you're publicly
but remember biden ran on a platform
that he was going to be a president of
the entire country
everyone says that though and then obama
said that in his campaign
if kamala harris doesn't gain the upper
hand well she will though because if
senate wins
both then she if it does if it does not
because you just said what if the senate
is ready no no no okay i'm sorry i'm so
what i was trying to say is
say they lose the senate and it's 50 50.
then it's a crap [ __ ] what
what leverage do republicans have very
very little what would it be actually
what would it be
you're at the negotiating table you're a
republican well you know we're just
we're not going to wait until 2022 we'll
show you okay no problem
well that whole thing you're saying that
they have so your midterms will be
decided the
minute any kind of legislation gets
passed
what social program has ever been
reverted back away
you got two years to pass anything you
want to pass so what leverage do you
have
whatever you pass i mean obamacare would
pass and then
trump tried to you know do anything to
it what happened to trump
you don't care about this and you don't
jimmy kimmel coming out and saying you
know this and jim
everybody coming out yeah you are like a
terrible human talking about uh trying
to reverse obamacare
the risk i think is that
if you get this blue wave so you're
you're anticipating massive deficits and
rising taxes
i mean you could put the economy into a
tailspin what kind of taxes when you say
rising taxes
at the federal level capital gains taxes
think about all of the gains people are
sitting on in
in the stock market right now and what
would happen
what the trickle-down effect would be i
mean we ran a graphic cool intelligence
a few days ago that shows that ceo
confidence
lags the s p 500 by one quarter in other
words ceos make decisions about head
count based on where their share
based on where their stock is trading so
just imagine
that short-term thinking you mean very
short-term thinking but yet they're the
ones that are
that that are in charge of the pink
slips let's see let me ask you a
question you said something and i don't
want to skip over that you said massive
deficits
and also uh taxes i think taxes isn't
the whole
point of tax increases to limit the
massive deficits to try to balance
budgets oh tell me about that it will be
an apples and oranges situation
complete apples and oranges you will you
will have billionaires pick their asses
up and leave the country
think about the exodus to florida and
texas and the number of companies
in the last week that have relocated
texas you're saying not only leave
i'm saying they're staying and what
happens to those people do they not pay
taxes do they renounce their citizenship
like what act
like go there as pat likes to say what
happens if they leave the country
these americans that just i'm out i'm
going to
i mean you can't you can renounce your
your your your citizenship if you want
if you're if you're an expat you still
have to
file taxes in the united states of
america you get a credit in the country
in which you live
so where are they going to would they
why wouldn't they just go to puerto rico
at that point you're still
in america but you know you don't have
to pay income taxes okay now you've
you've stumped me i can't i can't do the
puerto rico i stopped danielle dimartino
booth what
this i think i think alarm goes state
thing that would they have you only pay
four percent in taxes for 20. i have
friends in miami that have gone to
puerto rico straight up it's uh
now you know puerto rico has become a
tax haven a lot of private equity guys
hedge fund guys
he that's what he's saying yeah that's
what he's saying so so
other countries you're saying that in
the uh you're getting me ready for my
saturday
evening bar mitzvah i'm just letting you
know you're getting me in the mood
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]